ja es könnte sie geben ein
forschungsteam hat jetzt ein modell für
wurmlöcher entwickelt superschnell in
weit entfernte regionen des universums
gelangen wo löcher könnten das möglich
machen bislang allerdings lediglich in
science fiction erzählungen doch ein
internationales forschungsteam
präsentiert jetzt ein neues und super
spannendes modell das mikroskopisch
kleine wurmlöcher möglich erscheinen
lässt sind wohl löcher im all also weit
mehr als science fiction pur sind sie
möglich klicks um science and future
gibt es bei mal pro woche spannendes
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's
[Musik]
hoffentlich bekommen nicht nur das
raumschiff enterprise nutzt wie
selbstverständlich wurden löcher als
abkürzung im all auch in anderen science
fiction erzählungen spielen wurmlöcher
eine entscheidende rolle nämlich dann
wenn menschen in weit entfernte regionen
des universums gebracht werden sollen
heißt also es handelt sich um
abkürzungen im universum und manchmal
auch als ein fenster in die
vergangenheit oder zukunft denn
wurmlöcher ermöglichen diesen
geschichten auch zeitreisen diese
vorstellung entsprechen eher weniger den
vorstellungen die astrophysikerin und
astrophysiker von bohrlöchern abend
dennoch beschäftigen sich auch durchaus
seriöse forschende mit diesem thema
bisher handelt es sich um ein
mathematisch physikalische konstrukt das
in der theorie möglich sein könnte und
zwar unter ganz bestimmten
voraussetzungen
fakt ist auch dass es bisher nicht
gelungen ist beweise dafür zu finden
dass das gros welcher tatsächlich gibt
viele fragen sind offen falls sie
existieren kann man sie dann gezielt
nutzen oder gerät man zufällig hinein
wie sind sie beschaffen und wie genau
entstehen sie ein internationales
forschungsteam hat dazu jetzt eine
spektakuläre studie veröffentlicht
demnach scheint es ziemlich gut möglich
dass mikroskopisch kleine wurmlöcher
existieren könnten wie kommt das
forschungsteam zu diesen erkenntnissen
und was bedeutet das konkret sind
wurmlöcher also doch keine science
fiction sondern möglicherweise
realität die antworten auf all diese
spannenden fragen und noch viel mehr
jetzt bei pixum science and future
wurmlöcher tatsächlich haben diese
theoretisch vorhergesagten konstrukt so
gar nichts mit würmern zu tun lediglich
der begriff ist tatsächlich eine
analogie zu einem turm der sich durch
einen apfel frist dieser hat einen
deutlich kürzeren weg wenn er sich von
der einen seite auf die andere seite des
apfels frist länger wäre sein weg
dagegen wenn er über die oberfläche des
abfalls krabbelt oder ein anderes
beispiel wenn wir uns an tunnel von
deutschland quer durch die erdkugel nach
neuseeland graben könnten müssten wir
nur 12.000 kilometer zurücklegen anstatt
der 20.000 kilometer die der weg auf der
erdoberfläche lang ist eine analogie
also zu dem was sich physikerinnen und
physiker unter einem wurden noch
vorstellen die oberfläche des apfels
wäre hier das gesamte universum sven man
demnach also den ganzen weg durch das
universum nimmt ist dies deutlich länger
als die abkürzung durch das worum noch
doch der vergleich mit dem apfel kommt
schnell an seine grenzen denn die
oberfläche des obstes ist
zweidimensional und die raumzeit ist
vier dimensional zudem ist der apfel in
sich geschlossen die ameise könnte also
einmal um den ganzen apfel herumlaufen
wäre dann wieder dort wo sie ihren
spaziergang angefangen hätte beim
universum oder der raumzeit ist das ganz
kohlarten gar nicht so denkbar wegen
dieser unterschiede bevorzugen
physikerinnen und physiker lieber dem
vergleich mit einer tasse die einen
henkel hat die ameise könnte vom unteren
ende des henkels an der henkel
oberfläche entlang krabbeln um an das
obere ende des henkels zugelangt wenn
sie sich aber vom unteren henkel ansatz
über die tassen oberfläche zum oberen
henkel ansatz bewegt nimmt sie eine
abkürzung mathematisch gesehen
entspricht das schon eher den
vorstellungen die physikerinnen und
physiker von einem wurmloch haben
zurückgeht die idee der wurmlöcher auf
die gleichung von albert einstein in
seiner allgemeinen relativitätstheorie
gibt er ja davon aus dass gravitation
quasi nichts anderes ist als eine
krümmung der raumzeit wenn der raum also
gekrümmt ist könnte es gut sein dass
dieser eine komplizierte struktur
aufweist gut denkbar also dass zwei
eigentlich sehr weit voneinander
entfernte bereiche des raums auf einen
kurzen weg miteinander verbunden sind
ein stern geht davon aus dass das
universum vier dimensionen hat drei
raumdimensionen und die zeit als 14
demente zusammen wird so die sogenannte
raumzeit gebildet übrigens aus genau
dieser idee die das universum als ein
raum zeit gebildet mit vier dimensionen
beschreibt wurden auch die schwarzen
löcher vorhergesagt zunächst rein
hypothetisch bis es dann
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern endlich gelangen deren
existenz auch experimentell zu belegen
so beispielsweise der direktor des max
planck instituts für extraterrestrische
physik reinhard genzel er bekam im
vergangenen jahr 2020 einem physik
nobelpreis für den nachweis eines
schwarzen lochs im zentrum unserer
milchstraße und damit zurück zu den
wohnhäusern die gleichung von arbeiten
stammt aus dem jahr 1916 lassen also die
existenz von bohrlöchern zu konkret
liegt das an der zentralen gleichung der
allgemeinen relativitätstheorie bekannt
als die einsteinsche feld gleichung hier
wird die raumkühlung an einem ort in
direkte beziehung zu druck masse und
energie an genau diesem ort gesetzt
schwere objekte wie beispielsweise
sterne können die raumzeit krümmen das
kann man sich so vorstellen wie ein
betttuch in dem eine metallkugel liegt
fest steht die krümmung der raumzeit
entscheidet darüber wie sich licht aber
auch planeten und raumschiffe bewegen
doch es ist denkbar dass die raumzeit
auch ohne dass dazu tun von schweren
objekten gekrümmt oder verbogen wird ja
zumindest in der theorie ein wurmloch
könnte man sich demnach also vorstellen
wie einen extrem stark gekrümmten
bereich der raumzeit der zwei
miteinander verbundene trichter ähnelt
und zwei weit entfernte orte wie einen
tunnel verbindet rein mathematisch wäre
eine solche abkürzungen durchaus denkbar
doch klar ist auch solch ein wurmloch
wäre sehr instabil es würde sofort zu
einem schwarzen loch kollabieren wenn
ein raumschiff oder ähnliches hinein
fliegt somit wäre die verbindung zu
einem anderen ort des universums sofort
unterbrochen physikerinnen und physiker
haben in ihrem bisherigen modellen immer
eine exotisch nur theoretisch denkbar
der materie benötigt um das wurmloch
offenzuhalten achtung diese materie
müsste weniger wiegen als nichts also
eine negative masse haben doch die
aktuelle studie eines internationalen
forschungsteam lesben löcher jetzt auch
ohne die annahme dieser super exotischen
form der materie zu für ihre analyse
nutzen sie die klassische theorie der
elektronen dynamik und verbanden diese
mit elementen der quantentheorie und der
relativitätstheorie als materie die ein
wurmloch durchqueren sollte nahmen sie
bestimmte elementarteilchen an so zum
beispiel elektronen samt ihrer
elektrischen ladung
mathematisch nahmen sie die sogenannte
dirac gleichung zu hilfe diese formel
beschreibt die aufenthalts
wahrscheinlichkeit eines teilchens gemäß
der quantentheorie und der
relativitätstheorie das wird als
sogenanntes dirac feld beschrieben und
das ergebnis ist wirklich spannend denn
ihr modell lässt die existenz eines
mikroskopisch kleinen wurmloch zu dieses
erlaubt sogar das durchqueren von
materie heißt also das modell der
forschung ist es tatsächlich zu dass
zumindest ein elektron unbeschadet durch
ein minimum noch hindurch sausen könnte
und nicht nur das neben materie könnten
auch andere signale die winzigen tunnel
in der raumzeit durchqueren die
voraussetzung dafür das verhältnis
zwischen der elektrischen ladung und der
masse des rom los muss einen bestimmten
grenzwert überschreiten doch fest steht
leider auch interstellare reisen sind
durch diese mikroskopisch kleinen bogen
löcher noch lange nicht denken war das
forschungsteam selbst möchte jetzt erst
einmal das modell verfeinern eine der
entscheidenden fragen könnte es diese
eigenartigen gebildet tatsächlich geben
dazu sagt der astrophysiker
blask es salcedo der an der studie
beteiligt war wir vermuten dass die
bohrlöcher auch in einem vollständigen
modell existiert sind wurmlöcher also
eher science oder eher fiction oder ich
würde fragen future fest steht bisher
lief die fahndung nach realen
bohrlöchern ergebnislos und natürlich
muss nicht jede mathematische lösung
auch eine reale entsprechung haben heißt
also konkret obwohl sie keinen
widerspruch zur relativitätstheorie
darstellen muss es sie nicht unbedingt
auch in echt geben und wo löcher sind
keineswegs eine vorhersagen der
allgemeinen relativitätstheorie
anders als phänomene wie schwarze löcher
oder gravitationswellen hierbei handelt
es sich tatsächlich um phänomene die
direkt aus den einstein gleichungen
folgen und das ohne zusätzliche annahmen
die notwendig sind eine weitere frage
wäre eine solche reise durch ein
wurmloch überhaupt erstrebenswert die
bisherigen überlegungen dazu kommen zu
einer klaren antwort nein denn enorme
kräfte würden alles zerreißen und
zerquetschen wenn man den theoretischen
berechnungen glauben schenken kann wäre
der kanal auch nur äußerst kurz stabil
und würde dann wieder verschwinden wenn
wir menschen eine reise durch solch ein
wurmloch wagen würden wäre dies eine
reise ins ungewisse
sehr wahrscheinlich in den tod ob sie
schwarze löcher
riesenwellen und wurmlöcher interstellar
faktencheck hier habe ich die fakten des
wahnsinns science-fiction-films
interstellar überprüft hammer bilder und
hammer fakten also an gegen anschauen
und abonnieren das ist quasi
verpflichtend bis dann bleibt dran